لعنه الفراعنه العالم الغامض عند قدماء
المصريين اهي حقيقه ام اسطوره
صوص كتبت على جدران المقابر لمنع اللصوص
يعتقد انها تسببت في احداث ماساويه
لمكتشفيها
اسرار وقصص عن عالم السحر وما يعرف
بالعنات الفراعنه دفنت مع اصحابها منذ
الاف السنين اثارت فضول العلماء انبهر بها
الاعلام وتناولتها السينما المصريه
والعالميه
دفعنا الفضول للبحث في اصل هذه الحكايه
وحقيقته فذهبنا لنمسك ببدايه الخيط مقبره
توت عنخ امون بوادي الملوك بمدينه الاقصر
[موسيقى]
اشهر تلك الاساطير كانت هنا مع فتح مقبره
توت عنخ امون القرن الماضي احداث غامضه
طالت افراد البعثه ما حير العالم لسنوات
طويله فلنكتشف حكايه هذه المقبره وسر هذا
اللغز
ففي عام
1922 عثر عالم الاثار البريطاني هاورت
كارتر على اكبر كشف اثري حتى ذلك الوقت
مقبره الملك الصغير توت عنخ امون اول
مقبره تكتشف كامله لم تصل اليها ايادي
لصوص المقابر وبعد سته اشهر من اكتشاف
المقبره توفي ممول كشف اللورد كرنفون في
مصر متاثرا بلدغه بعوضه
وهو داخل فندق شيبرد في القاهره وروحوا
بتطلع حاجتين حصلوا النور بيفطي واعلى
واما الكلب بتاعه في نفس الوقت مات في
قلعته
طبعا بص في الكلام هتلاقي سنه 22 الكهرباء
في مصر
نمره اتنين ازاي
في الوقت ده ما مات اتصلوا بلندن ده عشان
تطلبي في الوقت ده ممكن تقعد اسبوع او شهر
على ما يردوا عليك
[موسيقى]
وفي السنوات القليله التاليه للكشف توفي
عدد من الذين كانت لهم علاقه مباشره او
غير مباشره بالمقبره ومنهم عالم مصريات
كان يعمل مع كارتر مات قبل انهاء عمله ما
عزز من الاعتقاد بوجود لعنه حقيقيه ليه
حصلت
لان اللي هو ممول هذه المقبره ادى الحق
الحصري لنشر الاخبار عن هذا اكتشاف العظيم
لجورنال انجليزي واحد اللي هو البريطانيه
فده خلى كل الصحفيين التانيين سواء من
انجلترا او خارجها يفتعلوا قصص عن لعنه
الفراعنه وده اللي خلى هذا التيرم وهذا
المصطلح
يظهر منذ ذلك الحين
[موسيقى]
ومنذ ذلك الحين اطلقت عباره لعنه الفراعنه
على عده احداث غامضه وايضا اساطير ومنها
وجود مومياء على متن سفينه تايتنك قبل
غرقها في بدايه القرن الماضي واحد خبير
امريكاني
جايب بوميه فكان هيجيبها على الباخره فبدل
ما يجيبها على الباخره اداها هديه الى
المتحف فالميه لمطرحتش على الباخره اطلاقا
[موسيقى]
مقبره بيتي تقع بالقرب من اهرامات الجيزه
وهي احدى مقابر العمال بنات الاهرامات على
جدران هذه المقبره كتبت نصوص تحذيريه تحذر
كل من يعبث بالمقبره او صاحبها
[موسيقى]
المصري القديم لما كان بيسيب نص اللعنه
على المقبره
على مقبره بيقولوا اسمها ايها الناس انني
لم افعل شيئا سيئا في حياتي وكل ما فعلته
كان صحيحا ولذلك احبتني الالهه وكل من
هيمص مقبرتي هتاكلوا التماسيح وفرس النهر
والاسود اعتقاد الفراعنه في البعث والخلود
وايمانهم الشديد بان المتوفى سيحيا من
جديد ليعيش حياه ابديه كان سببا في
استخدامهم للسحر ونصوص اللعنه وان كان
معظم علماء الاثار ينفون وجود تاثير لها
ما هي حقيقه لعب فرعون
لو قفلت الاوضه دي اللي احنا فيها 3000
سنه جوه هذه الحجره مومياء او بودع ادويه
بتطلع جراثيم غير مرئيه المومياء كلها
حاجات تتعفن بتطلع جراثيم علماء الاثار
زمان يقوموا داخلين بسرعه الجراثيم تقرصهم
يموتوا انا بعمل ايه دلوقتي بقوم فاتح
المقبره يوم او ساعتين او تلاته لما الهوا
الفاسق يطلع والهوى النقي يدخل وما فيش
حاجه
[موسيقى]
سمر باشات لصباح العربيه من القاهره